c'était le 14 décembre entouré de
journalistes d' enquête alexis navale
n'est qui est toujours en convalescence
en allemagne une femme qui prend le
téléphone et se passer pour l'assistant
du grand patron du fsb
celui-ci tombe dix fils seraient
constantes à 1 kudryavtsev un des
espions soupçonnés d'avoir participé à
l'empoisonnement navalni lui explique
qu'il a le mandat de faire un post
mortem de l'opération ratée après avoir
longuement hésité à répondre
[Musique]
l'agent fini par expliquer que s'attache
à lui était de faire disparaître toutes
traces de poison des vêtements que
portait navale n'est en arrivant à
l'hôpital
et ce avec une solution spéciale qu'en
aval nez et revient à la charge au
téléphone et lui demande sur quel
morceau de vêtement exactement et le
dise concentré
l'agent répond sur ses sous vêtements en
expliquant que le poison 9 hitchock
était dissimulée au niveau de la fourche
afin de pénétrer dans son sens lors du
vol de quatre heures qui le ramenait à
moscou dans cette vidéo qui a déjà fait
le tour du monde
on entend alex navalni hurlé avant de
perdre conscience dans l'avion il n'eut
été de la décision du pilote d'atterrir
d'urgence pour qu'il soit soigné
l'histoire se serait terminée autrement
dit constantin kudryavtsev pour alex et
navale les et son équipe cette
discussion de 45 minutes est une preuve
de plus que l'attak a été commandé par
le chef du kremlin
nos trois films achetés au travail que
je veux comme si on avait voulu
l'empoisonner il serait mort disait
vladimir poutine en souriant la semaine
dernière en rejetant encore toute
responsabilité le lendemain il rendait
hommage aux employés du renseignement
russe et soulignait la qualité de leur
travail
alex et navales né à bois être exilé
pour le moment il poursuit sa campagne
auprès des russes dans l'espoir de
déjouer la propagande de l'état
on nous promet le président vous m'en
dit navalni les preuves sont claires
nous devons répondre avec la vérité
bonjour peut être exigé une enquête si
thammarat altéré sco radio-canada moscou